so i'm not opposed proprietary software
i'm actually not an open source
zealot i love open source for the what
it brings but i also see the role for
proprietary software but what i didn't
like was the fact that i would develop
code
and publish it and then effectively
telling somebody here to run my code you
have to have this proprietary software
right and there's also culture around
matlab
as much because i've talked to a few
folks
math works great matlab yeah
i mean there's just a culture they try
really hard but it's just there's this
corporate ibm style culture that's like
or whatever i don't don't want to say
negative things about ibm or whatever
but there's a no it's it's really that
connection something i'm in the middle
of right now is is the business of open
source and how do you connect the ethos
of cooperative development with the
necessity of
of creating profits right and like right
now today you know i'm still i'm still
in the middle of that that's actually
the early days of me exploring this
question
because i was writing scipy i mean is it
a site i also had so i had three kids at
the time i have six kids now i got
married early wanted a family
uh i had three kids and i remember
reading i read richard stallman's post
and i was i was a fan of stallman i
would read his work i'd like this
collective ideas he would have certainly
the ideas on ip law i read a lot of
stuff but then he said you know
okay well how do i make money with this
how do i make a living how do i pay for
my kids all this stuff was in my mind a
young graduate student making no money
thinking i got to get a job and he said
well you know i think just be like me
and don't have kids right that's just
don't don't that's his take on this that
was just that was that was the what what
he said in that moment right that's the
thing i read and i went
okay this is a train i can't get on yeah
there has to be a way to preserve the
culture of open source and still be able
to make sufficient money to feed you yes
exactly there's got to be well so that
actually led me to a study of economics
because at the time i was ignorant and i
really was i'm actually i'm embarrassed
for educational system that they could
let me and i was valedictorian of my
high school class and i did super well
in college and like academically i did
great
right but the fact that i could do that
and then be clueless about this key part
of life
it led me to go there's a problem like i
should i should have learned this in
fifth grade i should learn this in
eighth grade like everybody should come
out with a basic knowledge of economics
you're an interesting example because
you've created tools that change the
lives of probably millions of people and
the fact that you don't understand at
the time of the creation of those tools
the basic economics of how like to build
up a giant system is a problem yeah it's
a problem and so i during my phd at the
same time this is actually in 98.99 at
the same time i was in the library i was
reading books on capitalism i was
reading books on marxism i was reading
books on you know what is this thing
what was it what does it mean yeah and i
encountered a basically what i
encountered a set of writings from
people that said they were the
inheritors adam smith but adam smith for
the first time right which is the wealth
of nations and kind of this notion of
emergent
emergent uh societies and realized oh
there's this whole world out here of
people
in the challenge economics is also
political
like because economics you know
people
different parties running for office
they'll
they they want their economic friends
they want their economist to back them
up right or to to be there to be their
magicians like the magicians in
pharaoh's court right the people that
are going to say hey this is you should
listen to me because i've got the expert
who says this
and so it gets really muddled right uh
but i was looking at from as a scientist
as a scientist going what is this space
what does this mean how do peop how does
paris get fed how does how what is money
how does it work i found a lot of
writings i really loved i found some
things that i really loved and i learned
from that it was writings from people
like von mises he wrote a peer to paper
in 1920 that still should be read more
than it is it's got i mean it was the
economic calculation problem
of the socialist commonwealth it's
basically in response to the bolshevik
revolution in 1917 and his basic
argument was it's not going to work to
not have private property you're not
going to be able to come up with prices
the bureaucrats aren't going to be able
to determine how to allocate resources
without a price system and a price
system emerges from people making trades
and they can only make trades if they
have authority over the thing they're
trading
and that that that creates information
flow that you just don't have
if you try to top down it right right
it's like huh that's a really good point
yeah the prices have a signal that's
used and it's important to have that
signal when you're trying to build a
community of productive people like you
would in the software engineering yeah
the prices are actually an important
signaling mechanism yeah right and that
money
is just a bartering tool right so this
is the first time i've encountered any
of this concept right and the fact that
oh this is actually
really critical like it's so critical to
our prosperity and
that
we're we're dangerously
not learning about this not teaching our
children about this you know so you had
the three kids you had to make some how
to make some money right i had to figure
it out but i didn't really care i mean i
was never i've never been driven by
money just need it right right
to eat so what how did that resolve
itself in terms of sci-fi so i would say
it didn't really resolve itself it sort
of started a journey that i'm continuing
on i'm still on i would say i don't
think it resolved itself but i will say
i i went in wide eyes wide open like i
knew that there were problems with you
know um giving stuff away and creating
uh the the
ex market externalities that the fact
that yeah people might use it and i
might not get paid for it and i'll have
to figure something else out to get paid
like at least i can say i'm not bitter
that a lot of people have used stuff
that i've written and i haven't
necessarily benefited economically from
it like yeah i've heard other people be
you know bitter about that when they
write or they talk like oh i should've
got more value out of this and i'm also
i want to create systems that let people
like me who might have these desires to
do things let them benefit so it
actually creates more of the same
not to turn on your bitterness module
but
there's some aspect i wish there was
mechanisms for me to reward whoever
created scipy and numpy because it
brought so much joy to my life i
appreciate that i mean the tip dark
notion was there i appreciate that and i
think but there should be a very there's
surely mechanism mechanism i totally
agree i would love to talk about some of
the ideas i have because i actually came
across i think i've come up with some
interesting notions that could work but
they'll require
anything that will work takes time to
emerge right like things don't just turn
overnight that's definitely one thing
i've also understood and learned
is any fixes
that's why it's kind of funny we often
give credit to you know oh this
president gets elected oh look how great
things have done and
i saw that when when i had a transition
in a condo when a new ceo came in right
and it's like the success that's
happening there's an inertia there yeah
right and sometimes the decision you
made like 10 years before is the reason
why the successes see right exactly so
we're sort of just running around taking
credit for stuff credit assignment has
like a delay to it yes
that this makes the credit assignment
basically
wrong more than right wrong more than
right exactly and so i'm like oh this is
you know that's the stuff i would i
would read a ton about you know early on
so i don't i feel like i'm with you like
i want the same thing i want to be able
to and honestly not for personally i've
been happy i've been i've been happy i
feel like i don't have any i mean we've
been done reasonably okay but i've had
to pursue it like that's that's really
what started my um trajectory from
academia is reading that stuff let me
say oh entrepreneurship matters
so i love software but entrepreneur but
we need more entrepreneurs and i want to
understand that better so once i kind of
had that
that virus infect my brain
it even though i was on a trajectory to
go to a tenure track position at a
university
and i was there for six years i was kind
of already out the door
when i started
you